Good morning John, it's Sunday, August 3rd,
2014.
And I love you.
You're a good brother, you're a good person,
and I'm lucky to have you in my life.
I don't know where I'd be without you, or
who I'd be without you.
You make me a better person, you help me make
better decisions, you've been a good person
to look up to as a child and as an adult,
and you just have good values.
Even thought apparently you told a bunch of
people at LeakyCon that I have a little bit
of a problem with showering when I was 10,
true.
You could of kept that one to yourself.
If you're confused with why I'm being so unironically
sappy right now, it's because today is Esther
Day.
In 2010 John asked Esther Earl, a nerdfighter
who helped inspire The Fault in Our Stars,
what she would like us as a community to do
on her birthday.
She said she wanted it to be a day to celebrate
the kind of love that people have inside of
families and friendships, not romantic love.
John as you put it last year, you said, "It's
a Valentine's Day for the rest of love".
Because, you know, we're obsessed with romantic
love, and I get that.
I understand.
But love is so much more than that, between
parents and children and siblings and friends.
It's the kind of boring everyday love that
ties the whole world together.
So on this day, we say "I love you" to the
people who we don't normally say "I love you"
to.
So, I'm asking, take some time out of your
day to do that thing.
It's just, it's a good thing to do, and if
that's not enough for you, it's what Esther
wants.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Good morning John, it's August 3rd, 2013,
and I love you-is it?
It's 2014, yup.